this is boss Mabel morning has come as
you can tell everything bright here
right now
well comparatively speaking it still
steel gray skies out because it's the
day before Thanksgiving the middle of an
explosion right now because of the
exposure so um there's about an inch of
snow on the ground it's quite festive
yes indeed um so uh heavy is the head
that wears the Fez was the message
Theron tis very true cuz Mabel says that
she can do a better job being a boss
than Stan can so they can make more
money on vacation so he goes on cash
wheel which is a wheel fortune show to
make a lot of money Mabel stays behind
gets her shoulder pads her chauffeur pad
suits and that do people remember when
women wore those like that was an
eighties thing it was so bizarre
um and it just did not look good now I
will last into the 90s as well I
remember Hillary Clinton they had some
shoulder pads yeah you don't like just a
little like it's okay to have a little
but they were like they're these really
thick well here she read the managerial
skills 1983 edition yeah a nice touch um
and yeah so she tries to do everything
friendly and just sort of you know is
generally a little too naive number two
Boston who's the number one you um and
lets people walk over her and realizes
that she has to do stuff she doesn't
want to do in order to run a business uh
I love it when dipper just like how I
have you horsewhipped every night for
the good of the company yeah um and
dipper goes and gets like a real monster
and it's too intense for people so here
we go back to the bullcrap there was an
interesting message there which is deep
down people just want to see crap which
at least for movies I think is very true
well it and so Mabel finds out she has
to be tougher and you know after
everything is done they almost break
even except like she has a dollar cast
and didn't know the word please uh in
the game show which upgrade looks like a
game in yeah me too ease and looks like
saying it looks like the word please can
make you money wouldn't you know it's a
prize but I thought that was really
clever um
and uh yeah they they agree to stand
should be the boss but and they both can
learn something so pre straightforward
but yeah there is something to like at
least which shows with us growing up in
movies and stuff like kid shows and
stuff uh there was always this thing so
you know always be nice and friendly and
follow your heart everything will be
okay
and I like how the show it does really
demonstrate no yeah you have to be
really tough and it's like always follow
your dreams do what's right and stuff is
like it know dipper found a monster you
know like this legit and it turns out
the people didn't want to see it or gave
them nightmares well I made somebody go
insane today yeah how about you uh and I
really liked it especially I think being
entertainment as well you serve no it's
like yeah there's a lot of stuff you
want to do but you also it's show
business yeah yeah what they mean what
comes before our heart out doing
something that we think is an incredible
piece of work and when it comes down to
like our fans of you like now give us
the crap like what we think is the crap
yeah they don't really happen but we
threw all this extra time and effort
into this night yeah that's all right
give us the shitty so the woman said
we're just like this didn't like what is
it the animating x1 is that still the
most popular oh I doubt it now yeah
before awhile like the most popular
video we had was like the top 11
nautious and a maniac moment cold when
he did it like I didn't like it was a
minute oh he tossed it off and it was
like the most viewed video for a long
time oh my god this video is amazing and
then we'll work hard on a particular
episode and be like this is good like
finally we've topped their shelf and so
like I feel I'm a theater like what now
the moat for the most part honestly I
mean again this is sort of compromised I
think it's episode makes like the ones
that we do pull up every you know the
man steel the Lorax and you know stuff
like that like they make a lot of use
and people respond to them um but yeah
there's always gonna know is there's
always something obviously like this is
gonna be like the one and then I thought
the Power Rangers one was gonna be like
huge like so I put a lot of time and
effort into that it's like it's okay
costumes yeah like so it does okay I
don't get be like famous you were just
yelling at a wall now that was amazing
like what different color wall is so but
I mean for the most part like it's fine
but yeah there is
be that cop right yes I you know as much
as we as much as the universe rats on
Michael Bay it still makes millions
people see the and I get like
that's the thing I can't argue with
Michael Bay doing the same saying I keep
doing it and I'm a mother aren't you
with the studio going like hey catching
like I mean you can argue maybe it's a
best to appeal to our lowest common
denominator but if it's a business yeah
I make money and like is this well
that's the same thing like okay the
people want crap give them crass so yeah
so it's it's always kind of a compromise
you know some people go all the way
Michael Bay goes all the way with the
bit I think Jay Leno went all the way
it's like well what Joe what joke will
hit the most people and you lose that
artistic intake and I let the people
work for me I'll interview them on the
street they can do the comedy another
scope oh my god that was like a
pitch-perfect Leno ever it's really good
um so yeah so it is a compromise leaving
five Leno fans out there for five there
are bunch of those guys that likes Conan
know that there aren't that many let
them Fast Five please
oh no there's play they just don't use
the internet cuz they're over the age of
only five yeah it's like our parents are
Baleno fan so um yeah so like as comedy
goes like it was okay but yes I don't
know whether there's something about the
message I like I guess tried to whirring
this one more than the jokes yeah it is
another switch-up if this is only switch
ups lately cuz I was like well if I
remember the story that I don't remember
the jokes more and constantly playing
the odds differently cuz it keeping you
on your edge surprise ha ha I'm not
giving any of this money to charity love
him um love that man yeah so I like that
I like again they both Sir Laurence and
Mabel has to be tougher but Stan theand
is also saying please and stuff like
that I thought that was a a good
connection with the show I guess I
thought that was so clever that the word
actually was pleased to win him all the
money and he didn't know it
um you know I thought that was really
gross goodbye who's that character from
what bones that gopher
I can't remember bard the bark it was
like the ladies man yes yeah like I just
it was very random I'm like
huh yeah I guess this a reference I'm
not quite getting or am I getting it is
this a low-key I don't know there's like
a game show character they had like a
big fro or something I'm not sure half a
man's like what is a love but it's just
it was this lady's man you speak up
oh that's a bad old yeah is it that
maybe more than 10 years old actually I
don't know it's the gap it more 10 years
old I I would imagine rice world we're
so old it's like that couch you're 35 in
my life is Oh Oh God well the nice thing
is generally a wheelchair well the nice
thing is you remember your mid midlife
crisis that got you into this business
by looking at all those old Generation X
like retro things yeah the the Arjun
Osiris is done now soon enough you get
to have a real midlife crisis in your -
it's gonna be great
it's like I can't look back I'm like I
don't have enough money to buy it for
our it's like my midlife crisis is
looking back at my other midlife crisis
we know so um it's still a good episode
I like I said I think I like the layout
of the story uh much more than something
instead of a good story over the camera
ages yeah hey you know it's no good
comedy or still good line to them and
stuff so yes good stuff
we'll see you um next week for us next
episode for you
will we be wearing the same clothes
accidentally tune in find out I'm gonna
wear a Mabel's sweater twincest